all right turning now to our more
perfect union series which aims to show
you that what unites us as americans is
far greater than what divides us
communities across the country are
coming together to support and protect
asian americans amid a rise in
anti-asian attacks
nancy chen introduces us to some of the
people trying to make the world safer
by offering everything from self-defense
classes
to free car rides but we want to warn
you some of the images in her report may
be tough to watch
with a background in martial arts she
calls herself new york tough
it would be good to know what to do when
it's like a frontal attack
but tyler chang says she's been forced
to get even tougher
i always check before i leave my house
now phone wallet keys and i make sure
that i have my pepper spray
and also my alarm did you have that
before is that something new
that wasn't something that i carried
until recently
that's because of recent scenes like
these a 31-year-old woman in new york
brutally attacked in the head with a
hammer a father of a one-year-old
knocked to the ground and punched
repeatedly in san francisco
and two women in baltimore were
hospitalized after this assault
involving a cement block i warn my
friends
you think that it won't happen to you
but
it would you just have to be prepared
mentally physically
just got to be on high alert being
prepared by taking this self-defense
class
you have to turn the whole way offered
for free
by boxer and filipino american roe male
bannon
with donations going to asian american
charities i had a lot of younger
people reaching out to me i've even had
some elderly
women taking it because most of the
elderly asian
americans are being targeted you have
these cowards
attacking people that can't defend
themselves people that should not have
to worry about these things
have to worrying about elders weighs
heavily on ching's mind
she and her mother have turned to a fund
called cafe madi cap
wherever she needs to go i try to put
her into a cab
and i'm able to track her as she goes
it reimburses fair rides for asian women
asian elderly
and the asian lgbtq community
people across the country raising about
200 thousand dollars
to pay for asian americans in new york
to take ubers and lifts
to feel safer this has helped us
immensely because we can go to our
vaccination appointments her doctor
appointments
my work interviews dentist madi parks
started cafe madi cab
with her own money commuting to work i
realized
i was just constantly scared as an asian
american i had the impression that
nobody's really helping us nobody's
protecting us
but that perspective definitely changed
as i was seeing
all the donations and the support that
was coming in
she says people of different backgrounds
around the world have contributed to the
effort
it restores humanity it gives me a
little bit
more confidence as well in other people
seeing the communities come together
it definitely restores faith for cbs
this morning
nancy chen new york
it's a shame it has come to this you
just hate to hear people describe
themselves as constantly scared
yes we have to get beyond the tribalism
of the time that we're in right now we
have to get to what's underneath it
because there's a lot of
unhappiness yes and that's
the root of what's what we're seeing
yeah and all these separations
yes i i like the point that they made in
the story you have to be a real
coward to attack people who are in who
are defenseless
that's well then as you say girl it
shouldn't it shouldn't have to come to
this no it really shouldn't no
no